danke schön mein schwein erika schnitt
jedes gut wobei erika langsam in die in
die jahre kommt letztes hat es die
probleme beim aufstehen das ist schon 23
mal passiert dass es hinter bayern
einfach ein bisschen lahm ist dann liegt
sind wir machen uns sorgen dann steht
sie wieder und dann frisst sie wieder
und da geht es ja so gut sehen ein
schönes gehege drinnen und draußen und
vermissen vielleicht etwas die
umliegende natur gerade jetzt wenn es
anfängt zu blühen würden sie vielleicht
lieber auf der wiese grasen aber als
letzte mal gemacht haben sind abgehauen
wir können sie nur mit hilfe von der
sprechen fonds die eine schippe einladen
die hessen die in heckler allerdings
leider ein frontlader von mais hatte
wieder zurück treiben deshalb haben sie
jetzt ihren schönen platz bekommt mit
dem sich schulen und des lebens freuen
so wie die anderen tiere und menschen
auf dem mars auch